california hasn't seen
anything like this in years more of the
state
burning this week than an entire
wildfire season
firefighters struggling to cope with the
calls for help
these men needed rescuing after becoming
trapped
a rare storm saw more than 12 000
lightning strikes
igniting more than 500 wildfires across
the state
then high winds and high temperatures
turned some
into infernos six lives have been lost
and 700 properties destroyed already
and as the fires threaten more populated
areas
blankets clothes the necessities
hundred thousand people are under
evacuation orders
five years back there was no fires every
year and now
it seems like every year's record record
fires every year
firefighters are barely sleeping as they
work to contain the fires ahead of
another lightning storm
but thick smoke is hindering fire
fighting from the air
this isn't just a typical fire that we
face day in doubt this is
unprecedented this is historic the fires
are growing so
fast many are too dangerous to approach
with relentless high temperatures and
high winds
this is only expected to get worse
peak wildfire season is still weeks away
and right now there's no end in sight
sally lockwood sky news los angeles